maintenant voici manson voulez qu'on
fasse rentrer mon invité sur bath est
une réaction par rapport à certains
emails qu'on a reçu ouais c'est vrai
qu'on n'est pas des puristes on n'est
pas forcément des linguistes mais des
gens qui sont irrités derrière leur
poste parce qu'il nous arrive parfois de
fans surtout à toi de tes risques moi je
suis pas là serait souvent il nous
arrive de faire des fautes de la cgt
yoda mon mètre cube est là juste pour
contrôler que les tournures
l'emplacement c'est sûrement corrects
bug musulmane mais le maître capello
tout
m
invité surprise de ma vie
[Musique]
un soir du mois
c'est un nom
la merde qu'ils aient vu c'était aux
folies bergères on faisait double jeu
j'en ai fumé un pétard ensemble après
les après l'émission ça m'étonnerait
beaucoup à la moi ça m'étonne pas du
tout hein alors simplement maître
capello est là pour un peu superviser
compte tenu des belles construction de
phrase et puis faire la chasse m
la chasse aux barbarisme et au foot en
général d'accord d'accord d'ailleurs je
vous soutiens des grains ce vous
reprocher le 23 avril sans liaison ouais
c'est vous qui avez raison ce que je
vous dit 3 avenue la liaison ouais mais
dans 3 avril
app store vers 6 heures
wimbée
les deux mois pour la semaine dernière
donc déchiré ses lettres de mécontents
il a arrêté la dope apparemment je vais
arrêter les mois besoin de juin
d'accord c'est bien m bien vous restez
avec nous donc et si l on utilise cet
outil
jean serrat but
mais reste et c'est tout et cela non
bien tu vas voir à quel point il est
précieux
peut-être pas sur le prochain habitait
qui est étranger mais oui il est assez
étrange effectivement j'accueille
marilyn manson
bonsoir vous parliez de drogue tout à
l'heure j'étais même pas encore arrivé
bonsoir marilyn donc vous appelez
marilyn comme monroe et manson comme
charles manson
ça vous est venu comment cette idée
d'accoupler le nom d'un tueur en série
satanistes avec le prénom d'une icône
glamour de l'amérique
b je voulais être la meilleure
représentation possible de l'amérique
votre surnom ses entés christ superstar
cela c'est bien que vous en pensez vous
hervé ont été créés superstar
c'était le nombre d'albums
la relève est assurée et marilyn manson
est une star donc du shock rock ce qu'on
peut appeler le shock rock alors dans la
tradition de badis toons avec sympathy
for the devil
ensuite il est black sabbath avec ozzy
osbourne alice cooper les sexpistols je
suis anarchiste je suis l'antéchrist
chantait johnny rotten alors on est très
contents de vous avoir ce soir parce que
vous êtes une star mondiale marilyn ça
vous plaît ça james l'armée tienne vous
rendez compte quand même dit ici se
manie sonne juste hier il ya un e-mail
qui va nous tomber beaucoup de gens
règlent leur téléviseur tout ça est
normal
peut-être que les gens croient qu'ils
regardent de chaînes à la fois une fin
de leur maître capello une chaîne
humaine
pas du tout c'est la même chose c'est
france 2 vient donc sortie de votre
album to man album et puis l'autre
raison de votre présence ici c'est le
succès mondial du documentaire de
michael moore qui s'appelle bowling for
columbine donc qui a été évidemment pris
mais un peu partout aux césars aux
oscars qui consacrait aux armes à feu
aux usa alors qu'hollande bein c'est une
université du michigan ou deux élèves
avaient ouvert le feu sur des camarades
et on s'était aperçu après que c'était
des des fans de vous voilà donc ces deux
raisons de on en parlera plus tard deux
raisons nous avoir ce soir mais on va
commencer par le début manson vous êtes
né le 5 janvier 69 et votre vrai nom
c'est brian hugh warner votre père était
un ancien mécanicien d'hélicoptère au
vietnam si je me trompe jamais moi et
oiseaux ce week-end - gérer une magasin
de meubles et les seuls moments
d'intimité de votre père avec vous
c'était quand ils vous emmener au stand
de tir pour vous apprendre à tirer
c'était un vrai moment d'intimité avec
lui et puis aussi il vous emmener au
concert de kiss un doux sans mon père
abel justement un maquillage qui s'est
mal un concert dans cette tenue
mon papa était découle s'attaque à ça
c'est votre papa votre maman celle
inverse elle était très possessive
traître est étouffante comme ça et quand
vous êtes petit marilyn manson vous
passez beaucoup de temps chez vos
grands-parents et vous découvrez la
sexualité dans la cave de votre grand
père voilà alors dans la cave du
grand-père à ça te plait ça dégénère
ah la la alors dans la cave du grand
père de marie ligne avec quoi maître
capello dans la cave du grand quart
d'heure matin il y avait des navets y
avait des lingerie féminine y avait des
godemichés enduits de vaseline les
godemichés et puis aussi des photos
zoophiles à aillas est assez juste suivi
c'est très drôle de grand père quand
j'étais gamin mon grand-père me
paraissait monstrueux mais en
grandissant je me suis rendu compte que
mon grand-père était bonne je suis comme
lui il est pas si mal que ça que je
n'aime pas trop les animaux enfin les
faits la zoophilie
ce qui n'a pas tiré un cheval dans celle
de jeter la pierre
j'aime pouvoir de son père alors donc
vous êtes à l'école est l'héritage
christiane school à et là évidemment
bizarre parce qu'il a aussi agi dans ce
sens que j'aime en faire un ami de
capello merci mais en plus donc voilà
vous avez dans cette école donc on vous
inculque des valeurs fondées sur
l'antéchrist et sur l'apocalypse alors
évidemment ça ça se travaille dans votre
tête vous essayez de vous adapter à
l'école vous essayez de vous adapter et
un jour vous leur apportez une photo
c'est des nuages dans le ciel qui
représente un ange et lui parce qu'ils
pensent à un vous pensez leur faire
plaisir
c'était ma grand mère ils m'ont dit que
c'était un faux et donc c'était la seule
fois j'essaie de m'intégrer vraiment
dans ce but qu'on m'a dit tout ça
c'était du bidon
j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté de croire ou des
c3 à ce que me racontait est alors au
lieu de vivre dans la peur d'avoir des
cauchemars il plaît j'ai décidé de
devenir ce dont j'avais peur juste mais
voilà alors là c'est la révolte dès
l'âge de 12 ans vous vous révoltez vous
êtes attiré par tout ce qui est interdit
vous êtes à l'époque vous est maigre
vous êtes couvert de boutons
vous êtes toujours tout seul enfin vous
avez une adolescence ça c'est assez
terrible en moi je me sentais invisible
et transparent c'était pas été rejetés
j'étais vraiment invisible on ne me
voyait pas et ça n'avait qu'à travers la
musique ou l'écriture quand j'étais
gamin je me suis dit je serai artistes
l'écrivain je pensais que j'allais
chanter parce que je ne savais pas
chanter mais bon et c'est comme ça que
j'ai trouvé ma propre voie je crée mon
monde et alors là en compagnie d'un
certain john cromwell et de son grand
frère au lycée vous commencé à vous
intéresser aux sciences occultes aux eau
qu une bonne liaison
football un tube non non mais c'est bien
parce que comme ça ça cautionne et c'est
une bonne idée non c'est le service
public service public c'est bien donc
vous intéresser avec ce dénommé john
cromwell aux sciences occultes aux
doctrines satanique 1 c'est l'époque où
vous visiter disneyland eux sous acide
des ca propose cet épisode rappelle un
peu cet épisode un peu surréaliste et là
où fait de la scène donc c'est le
scandale évidemment vous masturber sur
scène à un faux pénis qui éjacule un
liquide improbable vous jeter des n'a
pas eu recours à un accessoire dieu vous
vous jetez des poulets vivants au public
mais c'est vrai que c'est le public qui
les égorge alors marilyn au sujet de
votre cinquième album sur le précédent
vous avez déclaré
c'est l'histoire d'un innocent qui veut
faire partie d'un monde qui ne
l'acceptent pas il se bat il découvre sa
révolution et finit par devenir un objet
marketing
aujourd'hui vous êtes devenu un objet
marketing de ce que je fais de
l'exploiter et d'en faire ils ont une
marchandise et bien il yal'affaire donc
de colomb bein donc cette université du
michigan où deux fans ouvrent le feu sur
leurs camarades et les médias américains
vous accuse alors vous répondez on peut
pas accuser shakespeare de pousser les
gens au suicide parce qu'il a écrit
roméo et juliette
enfin c'est vrai quand même que les gens
qui ont tiré sur leurs camarades étaient
des fans de marilyn manson accès
en fait il fallait un coupable donc on
m'a brandi un peu embêtant c'est cette
effigie du coupage et j'ai décidé de ne
pas répondre à tout cela parce que je ne
voulais pas justement donné les
alimenter cette flamme
les gamins voulait justement acquérir
une espèce de célébrités malsaine
américiain tenait justement ce qu'il
recherchait et je voulais pas y
contribuer donc d'associer le nom
marilyn manson à cette horreur et en
fait marine monde c'est bienvenu
puis de colombani cité ironiquement
c'est quand même assez injuste d'être
attaqué par mon propre appareil de
détection à la droite quand il a dit
actuelle et il n'a pas trait du vêtement
par actuellement en fait
venez la finesse vous dites que cette
histoire finalement permettait d'oublier
monica levinsky parce qu'à l'époque
c'était le grand scandale de monica
lewinsky on oublie aussi grâce à ça les
bombes balancer sur le kosovo et vous
dites c'est moi qu'on accuse de
provoquer un comportement violent alors
que finalement à la même époque les
états unis bombardé la yougoslavie
absolue est exactement de seine comme
les seigneurs locaux en dire autant de
ce qui se passe actuellement c'est à
dire qu'on va continuer à censurer mes
mots mes images ou mais où ma musique
mais en fait il ya un véritable
duplicité du gouvernement et moi mon
rôle c'est justement de mettre cette
démarche défi il faut que moi si
l'amérique représente la démocratie moi
je dois représenter la liberté
d'expression ce n'est pas quelqu'un
comme moi qui aurais personnes justement
pour remettre en cause les fausses idées
nous à moi qui irai que revient le rôle
justement de remettre en cause certaines
politiques certaines valeurs ce qui ne
veut pas dire que je déteste les jeux
l'acceptent parce qu'elle est mon rôle
c'est en faire un pays plus intéressant
plus divertissement en étant beau gosse
d'accord alors dans le film quand
michael moore vous pose la question et
vous dites qu'est ce que vous diriez au
lycée columbine et vous répondez je les
écouterai ce que personne ne fait rien
et c'est quelque chose que je deviens un
départ avant l'incident de koloma
n'était pas la première fois qu'une
telle tragédie se produise c'est pas moi
qui ai inventé la violence et ce n'est
pas non plus les gamins de colobane
comptes a vanté la violence du manager à
cette tendance
une tradition de s'autodétruire et ça
c'est quelque chose que j'ai toujours
évoqué dans ma musique alors c'est quand
même assez curieux qu'on me montre du
doigt parce que tout ce que je dis tout
ce que je chante c'est un commentaire ce
cette triste réalité
il est vachement sage 1 1 je trouve
qu'on qu'elle était anéantie bien de
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude
abonnez vous y mettez un peu de bleu